thank you so much that means means so
much to me having lost my husband last
year after 65 years and we would come to
this Academy every year and I miss him
and that made up for it and it was so
loud I know he heard it but my daughter
I just realized something I'm older than
the Academy plus four months or maybe
five I'm very proud of that just keep
moving when we were making on the
waterfront the studio wardrobe
department dressed me in a simple navy
blue coat which I wore throughout the
movie as my character falls from marlon
brando a dock worker for North by
Northwest to look glamorous while
falling in love with Cary Grant director
Fred Hitchcock took me to Bergdorf
Goodman we're together we show some of
the beautiful wardrobe and my favorite
was always the black dress with the red
roses do you remember that ladies but
I've also had the privilege of working
with some of the leading costume
designers in the motion picture industry
and it has produced including the
legendary a time Oscar winner and 35
time nominee Edith Head
she was such a she was such a wonderful
lady and one time I was making a film
with her and the producers were there we
had a very serious meeting and they left
and then she said come on Eva Marie come
into my office and we're gonna do this
ourselves well I like that idea
these next artists continue her
tradition of bringing imagination
innovation and duty to the screen here
are the nominees in costume design
Beauty and the Beast costume design by
Jacqueline Durham darkest hour costume
design by Jacqueline Durham
badge on thread costume design by mark
bridges
the shape of water costume design by
newest sukira Victoria and Abdul costume
designed by console Mota oil they're all
wonderful movies this year mark bridges
fandom thread this is the second Oscar
in third
in this category for the artist
Oh first I want to thank Paul Thomas
Anderson for writing this amazing script
and having me design it thank you Paul
to our wonderful actors Daniel Leslie
Vicki the whole company of actors who
were such great collaborators on this
film my brilliant brilliant crew in
London who worked tirelessly to make
beautiful dresses and get them on camera
thank you and of course the Academy
thank you very much
[Applause]